ich will ihnen gleich noch einmal zeigen
was karl lauterbach dazu gesagt hat und
auch zu der frage gesagt hat was mit
weihnachtsfeiern passieren könnte also
sehen wir dass die kann noch sehr viele
menschenleben kosten da ist es wichtig
dass die menschen vorsichtiger werden
dazu gehört möglichst auf betriebliche
weihnachtsfeiern in innenräumen zu
verzichten an weihnachten in kleineren
gruppen zu feiern und nicht zum karneval
zu gehen forsch mit sicherte mit dem
kopf sie gehen zum karneval und
weihnachtsfeier findet auch statt
was denken sie dann wenn sie so was
hören und lesen ich finde wir sollten
schon auch mal an die eigenverantwortung
der menschen auch appellieren und wir
haben viel die letzten minuten
diskutiert und auch gehört über die
möglichkeiten auch mit der pandemie
umzugehen zu leben und auch bestimmte
dinge am laufen zu halten und ich sehe
kein problem form eine weihnachtsfeier
jetzt gibt es natürlich solche und
solche weihnachtsfeiern aber wenn man
gepflegt sich vielleicht zum abendessen
trifft und die impft ist sich auch
nochmal zur vorsicht auch testet dann
finde ich ist es schon auch eine
möglichkeit zusammenzukommen und bei all
dem gesundheitsschutz müssen wir auch
mal an die gesellschaftlichen die
sozialen folgen denken und viele sind
auch in dieser phase ist es sehr kurz
vor dem zitter bleiben ist das dein
panikmache was der lauterbacher betreut
ich finde schon weil wir haben
instrumente und wir haben ganz viel
erfahrungen aus den letzten 18 monaten
und genau das müssen wir anwenden und
damit können wir weiter kommen und
unsere gastronomie und hotellerie hat
auch gezeigt dass es nie die treiber
auch der pandemie war da wurden
hervorragend funktionierende hygiene
konzepte umgesetzt und deswegen
appelliere ich an die eigenverantwortung
an die vorsicht und rücksicht natürlich
auch für die bullen gruppen aber dennoch
zu schauen was geht und auch damit
umzugehen wenn sie sagen das ist
panikmache was treibt dann aus ihrer
sicht in lauterbach solche dinge immer
ich jetzt werden wir ein lachen im
hintergrund was herrn lauterbach um oder
antreibt kann ich hier nicht sagen ich
finde nur wir müssen aufpassen die
pandemie hat ja auch mit der
gesellschaft viel gemacht und wir haben
zum teil eine sehr aufgewühlte situation
und deswegen finde ich müssen wir
verantwortungsbewusst und seriös mit den
fakten umgehen jetzt habe ich gerade in
unserem splitscreen nicht sehen können
wer von ihnen gelacht hat bei der
aussage überein lauterbach aber es war
ein männer lachen also herr gassen oder
her stört wer was richtig auto mich hier
ich halte mich ich habe gelacht und der
in der grund ist eigentlich nicht der
dass das thema nicht an genug ist denn
letztendlich ist es ja unheimlich
wichtig dass wir uns für die richtigen
dinge entscheiden aber ich glaube jetzt
an die vielen menschenleben zu
appellieren die manier
kosten wird das erinnert mich an den
fußball an die fußballstadien wo ja auch
viele tausende sterben sollen an die
eltern die dann
verloren gehen wenn die kinder sich
infizieren und die eltern also das ist
ja auch eine gewisse kette die man die
torlinie in der argumentation wo ich das
ist mein kurzes spiel und herstellers
müssen kurz einmal erklären also erlaubt
aber hat immer wieder in den vergangenen
monaten zum beispiel bei der
fußball-europameisterschaft und anderen
events vor vielen toten gewarnt und
gemahnt warum macht er das dann immer
wieder ja das kann ich nicht sagen so
was was richtig ist auf jeden fall ist
das die jetzt ganz genau darauf achten
müssen welche auswirkungen die winter
welle und die zunehmende mobilität und
die zunehmende kontakt haben werden dann
die anzahl der erkrankungen definitiv
nun eben die hospitalisierung werden
zunehmen und die muss man sicherlich an
der einen oder anderen stelle auf jeden
fall auch dann nicht weil ich die
kontakte reduzieren und dann würde aber
sehr gut ein von mir schon der oft
erwähnte stufenplan helfen wo man
bestimmte parameter hat
validierungs raten in die station
bewegungen richtig habe ich auch die
altersspezifische inzidenz und dann auch
klar kommuniziert mit der gewissen
positiver denn darauf was man macht wenn
diese parameter eintreten und sagt man
dann auch wieder locker wenn sich
massive positive agenda ansprechen herr
gassen gibt es bei ihnen keine wahl oder
weihnachtsfeiern oder die aus wie
gefordert von lauterbach also ich kann
es jetzt aus düsseldorf nur sagen dass
hier offensichtlich karneval stattfinden
sollen und zwar auch mit normalen
veranstaltung allerdings unter zwei
bedingungen
ich glaube das werden wir auch in weiten
teilen sehen und man muss es gar nicht
auf den karneval kaprizieren
grundsätzlich gilt ja für veranstalter
haben in der vergangenheit ja gesehen
dass auch ver anschauen mit vielen
menschen sicher durchzuführen sind das
kernproblem wird sein ich glaube das
muss man einfach realistisch einschätzen
da wird mehr stört wahrscheinlich recht
gewährt werden erleben dass sich in den
nächsten monaten aller voraussicht nach
mehr oder weniger jeder der nicht
geimpft wird infizieren wird da können
wir maßnahmen eingreifen die bremsen
diese entwicklung vielleicht ein wenig
aber ich glaube es ist eine trügerische
sicherheit wenn die leute meinen weil
sie nicht zum kader gehen oder
vielleicht noch in der u bahn der maske
tragen sind sie davor geschützt sich mit
corona zu infizieren der einzige schutz
wird letztendlich die impfung seien und
die werden wir bei insgesamt vielen
älteren dann mit einer dritt impfung
ergänzen das posten bis dahin schon
dabei jüngern sind macht das müssen die
studien zeigen ob das hilfreich ist das
kann vielleicht jetzt noch nicht
wirklich spannender kassen dann hieße
das ja umgedreht ich kann wenn ich
geimpft bin oder auch nicht zu sagen das
macht keinen unterschied dann ohne maske
auf die weihnachtsfeier gehen oder zum
karneval weil das mag ein erhebliches
shop siegel soll nicht geimpft sind und
das was braucht jeder davon anekdotisch
erzählt hat ist ja ganz richtig es gibt
menschen die glauben tatsächlich wenn
ich jetzt den winter noch zu hause
bleibe dann ist das im frühjahr vorbei
da mag durchaus auch das zum teil
unsinnige gerede von einer zero kugel
strategie zu beigetragen dass man den
leuten die illusion verkaufen wollte
wenn ihr euch sechs wochen an die
maßnahme ist dass iris wie durch
zauberhand verschwunden und das genau
würde es nicht tun und es wird uns immer
wieder begegnen wir werden
wahrscheinlich erst ruhe im sinne einer
endemischen lager seines normalen
auftritt von kona wie in trance haben
wenn tatsächlich der großteil der
bevölkerung geimpft oder genesen ist die
30% nicht geimpften werden aus meiner
sicht relativ bald zu den genesenen
gehört wenn sie sich nicht vorher impfen
lassen reicht es dann wenn die ampel die
dinge die sie jetzt angekündigt hat in
den bundestag einbringt ja klar ich dass
ich vorhin diese verwirrungen die herr
kretschmer mit der pandemischen sich die
pandemische sind die epidemische lager
nationaler tragen heute das war ja ein
regelwerk ein juristisches regelwerk
über verordnung durch das
bundesgesundheitsministerium regieren zu
können dass man das sehr wurde in andere
gesetzgebungsverfahren fassen kann oder
in landesverfassung dann maßnahmen zu
erreichen die bei entsprechend lokalen
auffälligkeiten oder der starken zunahme
von inzidenz ergriffen werden das ist ja
ohne frage richtig rein nordrhein
westfalen hat beispielsweise solche
regeln der landesverfassung niedersachse
hat sie auch wahrscheinlich andere
bundesländer auch also wir brauchen
nicht zwingend epidemische lagen
einander tag weiter damit die länder je
nach instanzen entsprechende maßnahmen
ergreifen können das sind zwei paar
schuhe das verwirrt die menschen nur